Squarespace Squarespace make next move
squid swiss mice make your next website
Squarespace make your website tight
squeeze sip your website square space
you can do it if you stupid square
Squarespace if you want if you have a
business and you try to make money from
people you need a good website if you
don't have a website what are you a drug
dealer even drug dealers have websites
now they have them on tour browsers or
some [ __ ] like that
Squarespace smooth websites it'll make
it look like it'll make it look great
you might even get laid because you got
a dope website linked to that [ __ ] on
your bumble tinder profiles check out my
website it's a good website is guys
successful and then you meet this person
because your website looks good and they
connect you they have a similar business
but you fall in love you work together
you build a family you get a nice house
you get joint bank accounts and your
life just changes because you had a
great website go to squarespace.com use
promo code Hannibal get 10% off
squarespace.com use promo code
Hannibal get 10% off wear space
[Music]
[Applause]
Hannibal Buress
Tony trib al Jackson we hear it
Los Angeles chillin man it's a nice Los
Angeles as day just typical la 70
something nice people wear a wide range
of stuff this is why your rent is $400
more than anywhere else in the country
like right outside that's why period
beautiful out here is nice today and all
some people just this type of weather
range man yesterday I was out in jeans
and a t-shirt and we at the spot
downtown LA it was some lady all she had
on fur coat and a fur hat yeah and I had
on because it my winter brain was oh
yeah that makes sense and I look down
and when I was wearing on wait a second
yeah I knew where exact you know you got
on a fur hat see what things she was
sweating if you lived here you'd be
dying to break your jacket out cuz you
got like final jackets you really like
yeah and so when it's like 68 you're
like hey hey it was crazy teacher well
understand yep and that's the best way
to flex is the wear your best outerwear
gear yeah because you can't really flex
that hard with just a t-shirt now it's
just about it's really about how you
look summer gear about how you look as a
person
yeah winter gear fall you can dress yeah
that's why it's yeah San Francisco is
the city for light jackets uh-huh
there's always light jacket weather in
San Francisco we were at the spot last
night they will play a juke music I just
thought it was DJ spins birthday I don't
think I've met him before because
Chicago DJ I know I know the name and I
saw today be playing Juke
yeah I want to go hear some goddamn doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo I
wanna go hear that [ __ ] we went last
night music was good nobody was dancing
to they were treating Juke music like it
was goddamn J Dilla listening session
[Laughter]
hmm everybody was kind of bobbing their
heads yeah it's basically like Low End
Theory with juke music yes so [ __ ]
bizarre cuz when I walked in the way I
walked it like it is kind of was a
semicircle surrounding and I looked at
my oh [ __ ] they all looking at somebody
else somebody must be foot working in
here cuz I like I see was the people at
first I could I just see people looking
at something and I step all the way and
they were just staring at the DJ yeah
there's music that makes girls feel sexy
and that kind of music it like lends to
dance it cuz even whether you know it or
not when you see even just a group of
girls dancing you're like how far can I
get up you know whatever yeah it may be
I dancing my girl but like there are
certain music there just makes you focus
on the DJ yeah and like that's a lot of
musical oh man they even have like an
audio-visual yeah they experienced you
almost like watching a movie standing up
yeah yeah you had drunk and so if I feel
like if you try to dance with a girl
that like low in she [ __ ] are you doing
you have to kind of dance on you know it
depend on the song because they'll start
playing some they'll play some kendrick
cuts in there and some regular stuff you
might here to dance joint but Juke
nobody was joking nobody was footwork
and then I almost felt like I should
footwork but then I realized I'm almost
34 I can't just be out here recklessly
foot working without stretching I might
tear my ACL and then we'll [ __ ] get
that and they put it up on vine it
revitalizes vine they're back now it's
all out of control man I don't think a
single person even knew how to do cuz
we're leaving there was there was a
little circle breaking out and it was
like this weird hippie looking chick
doing your dance moves yeah I was like
she's definitely not foot working I've
never footwork tap up some people might
not know what we're talking about
talking about Chicago juke music
footwork it is a dance you do to it and
when I was in high school dudes deck of
footwork got all the girls yeah
everybody if somebody would just be beat
you'll just break out in the hallway
somebody had to start beating on the
lockers they'll be making a beat up boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom and then
people just started dancing yeah
and it's just a I guess it's part
confidence and part nimble it's like
black people Riverdance sorta yeah
[Laughter]
footwork footwork is good like non corny
Riverdance it's just like fast up rock
basically breakdancing you took up
rocket stuff before
yeah it's fast upright you never really
go a proper go down yeah yeah and it's
different it's different styles I never
done it in public that's my main regret
in life
imma do it GoFundMe what about what if I
booked a comedy show in Chicago fill it
as a comedy show but it's just me doing
a 45 minute foot working solo be a
weird-ass art project but I booked a
show
I booked at it like a $3 ticket rights
or something yeah so you go CDs feet
dance I paid $3 if there's a thousand
people there how many states are the
under that how many people stay to the
end so they end of a 45 minute days am i
killing it who's there at minute 36 am i
taking a breath am i killing it do I
have visuals behind me Andy of a DJ I
have a DJ I think it depends on my
intensity and if I'm willing to maintain
it yeah if I can maintain my intensity I
feel like with my facial expressions and
passion I can hold 80% of that audience
for 30 minutes just dancing cuz
everything this is now what I came here
for but I'm here already I gotta commit
to this some of them got to commit I
drove him from the suburbs ready
goddammit I feel like the last five
minutes those are your hardcore fight
yes because a minute 40 dudes like a man
let's we got reservations yep that's my
next project going in I'm writing that
down checking it off footwork heart
didn't
who Tommy Chong didn't he like used to
end his when he started doing stand-up I
think I heard he did like the last ten
minutes of his acts him and his wife
would like ballroom dance on the state
like they never every show robably yeah
sounds like you wouldn't make something
like that up sounds like a good way to
kill ten minutes but no jay-z did that
crazy member when he did that [ __ ] at
the MoMA he played the same song over
and over like three hours or some [ __ ]
but they filmed it for the video huh oh
and he did do it at the MoMA so people
knew they were getting into some weird
stuff yeah I'll talk about this
surprising people with wisdom you said
he used to just dance at the end of his
set like him and his wife would just
dance ballroom dance like waltz like on
the stage what they make faces anything
oh no I think they were just dancing I'm
sure their audience - just stoned and
they're like this is probably beautiful
or whatever but you know I think people
just gonna come I mean cuz I don't think
he's hammering out a hard 45 minutes at
I'm sure he's got like 26 yeah dancin
Q&A Q&A anybody got questions out there
what's the other what's the other
fillers oh so what do you do for a
living
steal the time fillers oh the ultimate
time killer is a dance contest
you ever seen comics do that in the
middle of the set at the end of the
second you got like 36 and you're like
I've seen no names please I've seen a
lot of comics too like got famous but
didn't have time yes they'd be like
alright let's have some fun in here oh
hey you they would always pick like they
Central Catholic like an old white dude
like a hot blonde black girl with a big
asses on and just make them like in like
the old white guy dances at my last and
like this whole thing's happening and
like they don't realize like oh I just
took 11 minutes this [ __ ] said the
fake dance cut the time it takes to get
people out of their chair and yeah
they're yeah do it any ID no names but I
know someone [ __ ] that make some
dough off some day fake dance oh yeah
35 it's not gonna it's not gonna get
better by the tenant by the by the late
you know the Late Show oh man yeah
there's a it's a weird thing man to just
go on stage and just when you walk up
say that you know you don't have enough
time to fill that's that takes more
balls and just doing stand-up regular
like to just know you're you gotta kill
ten minutes about usually nothing and of
write a a wave though where you can get
into the pocket of a subject and then
okay I'm in this and you get a eight
minutes or ten minutes that you didn't
have or just riffing on something with
you know so is but you mean knowing you
only got 30 minutes and being scheduled
to do an hour that's a lot of time does
a lot of time and especially if Ike I
think the problem is is not that you've
got knowing you got 13 you got to do
hour
I think it's when you're first thirty
ain't going that great it you know it's
like if you hate this [ __ ] I got nothing
okay I mean are there comics that aren't
good at writing jokes but awesome at
riffing so they have they're like 20 and
then they depend on another 24 just
crowd forked [ __ ] those commas in two
full sets of riffing mmhmm yeah but just
do it well and back in back I'll just do
a full riffing set and kill and kind of
have an arc with it and loop people back
in and have callbacks and [ __ ] I haven't
seen him in a while but I remember
seeing him several years back at Zanies
and he would just kill bro no I've seen
people like go to a decline and then go
to the 10 o'clock yeah cuz it's that it
wasn't Patrice like that too was Annie
able to do [ __ ] like that he could not
mitrice will come in with a set yeah but
he was great working with the crowd but
his whole set wouldn't be that but if
you saw him back-to-back so
that would be a lot of variance I think
yeah but no Ian bagg just straight up
was do a fool just riff set yeah let's
God take skills man do and it's like
I've seen every it's always a different
show that's awesome because I've seen
people that have they have what I call
fake improv where that they'll go at you
but they kind of know like they're like
they already have a joke for if you're a
garbage man or you're a cop
they already have that kind of joke
store yeah but Ian's [ __ ] is just like
every show is like curated just for that
audience
yeah ma [ __ ] Tony yeah
Tony what's up man Tony clothes on a
place man Tony bought a place I heard
about that you're grown man now right
before I flew out yesterday at noon
yeah I met with the attorneys signed the
paper got the keys
yep got to the airport and didn't get to
check out the new crib
but yeah it's weird I'm gonna have to
start deciding on what paint I was gonna
say that's the cool things like you get
to figure out to you what paint you
gonna you yeah blinds
I'm gonna buy furniture instead of
taking it secondhand from my parents all
oh yeah uh yeah that's though invest in
a nice vacuum cleaner stuff like that
yeah you don't have a vacuum cleaner now
I do but it's like a it's a crappy one
so I'm gonna buy like a nice one nice
for your crib nice rip yeah yeah some
dope like I want to get some dope [ __ ]
I'm sick of this IKEA furniture [ __ ]
target lamps I want to get like some
good furniture like but buy it piece by
piece there's a lot of people listening
like I have IKEA furniture
I hope Target think I'm doing all right
destroyed somebody's a million at Target
Mossimo v-neck great t-shirt right now
I'm not knocking on it I'm just saying
I'm the I'm done with that I wanted it
you know I want to take it up a level
take it up a notch and buy some nice
[ __ ] that I can like pass off to my kids
or something if I know you've got to
start a family
no I'm not gonna start a family you just
let it sit pass to your kids you got a
spot a place you bout to get new vacuum
cleaner
means you bout to go impregnate somebody
and so you have somebody to share that
vacuum cleaner with you said what did
you say last night you're like Jake's
gonna be looking at you different now
man cuz you ain't you a homeowner yeah
homeowner doc they gonna be looking at
you different you kept saying that it's
kind of scary though I wasn't making
[ __ ] Mike this is the beginning of time
women are like I need shelter yeah you
do they can provide you know and you
have both you got and caveman terms you
have a fire and a cave you got a rump
roast rotate over that fire and they're
like I could slide right up in here I
could draw some draw some sticks [ __ ] on
this wall Oh
yo for real Tony no more yeah I rented
my whole life and it's gonna be wit yeah
it's it's it's a shift I don't know
where it's gonna go but I hope it
doesn't affect my dating life that much
uh I don't know I can't call it man it's
gonna enhance it I think I'm gonna be I
think the older you get you're just
gonna be dating more and more like
professional chicks that don't fall for
your [ __ ] when you're [ __ ] with a
doctor you do you do your dumb line
that's working on that wrist yeah like I
don't know I'm waiting on Hannah Bush
like I got an appointment are you gonna
meet me at night I don't know I guess
I'm usually [ __ ] don't fall for your
dumb [ __ ] that's the hard shoes like
when you start [ __ ] with women it's
like okay I got two Benz yo la is kind
of put me in I'm in a mellow mood man
yeah it's a it's a choke place in Shelly
no I haven't been out late I've been
just kind of mellow I've been taking my
weed pills hmm
it's great this [ __ ] is great I mean how
do you feel cause we were we were all
just in New York right yeah yeah so like
New York is just crazy to me every time
I go to New York and get back to Chicago
I feel like I need a wine down period
yeah and then you go here which is
completely opposite and we literally
have done this in the past two weeks
like how do you guys feel cuz this [ __ ]
makes me feel like so polar I feel you
know bipolar feel great man and I just
wanted to tell everybody else feel great
thank you for listening thank you to our
new sponsors subscribe share all the day
yo that's broadcast five stars.we you
know I went to uh that's the weed pills
talking yeah oh and I got to tell you
about home he's got arrested oh yeah
yeah I went to uh I told you about this
dis craziness I went to Kansas City yeah
to watch Invicta MMA yeah women's MMA
that's where cyborg used to fight mm-hmm
some other UFC is this where it's like
the best of Invicta eventually we'll
make it so you have said you say it's
triple a for women fighters
I would tell not to disrespect him not
to this but they're they're trying to
get to the next level right yeah it was
definitely triplet where sometimes I
want you know somebody will you not be
so hot in UFC and have to go down for a
little bit or people will go back and
forth so yeah it is
triple-a for women's MMA and so I saw it
on a calendar or something so I say we
go to Kansas City I've been going to the
UFC events you go to Kansas City and
check this [ __ ] out
$35 tickets for about three rows off but
it's a small it's like an 800-seat a
thousand see theater or hall or whatever
how many fights a lot of fights
I want to say eight fights $35 $35
goddamn bargain this sounds like an ad
almost sounds like the damage should be
bringing its model to seconds $5.00 a
fight it was great but yeah eight sounds
like a good number what it was super
intimate yeah where somebody went
somebody win a fight and then later
there's be sitting in the stands is a
plugin like help we do it like a comedy
showcase do you set that you just kind
of hang him watch you having a drink at
the bar the same thing that's good
everyone the first fight
she knocked this check out and then
later on in the second half of the car
she was sitting directly in front of me
regular clothes this chili
so how was that cook that was cool this
one dude yelled at a fight I want to get
into that no no it wasn't my I don't
know it was a fighter that was talking
to somebody after her fight she was
sitting down and said she was talking to
somebody I guess it was smiley from her
team just yelled down but no and then
she just left I think kind of control
over you get her Twitter it was so weak
because we were just looking around
oh she just beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody broadcast around the world and
in front of people she just beat
somebody up and down some dudes from the
balcony and obviously I don't know if
there's a coach so whoever he's yelling
at her in front of everybody was whipped
but it's a good fight good time why
start a fight it was some finishes cuz
he was some there was some mom there was
some mixed matches I showed you
something to fire he watched it was some
mixed match like it was definitely some
people what anything was setting you up
to get there destroy in and I just
fighters cuz I'm that I'm still a very
casual fan I know the sport a little bit
but I just fight about superficial
things one is music
sometimes fighters have some cheesy-ass
walk-on music they walk into Britney
Spears and insightful [ __ ] you'd have
other fighters that this [ __ ] is really
on the nose and it's just one of the
angry Eminem song because angry in those
songs you oh this is perfect walkout
music I'm a soldier
lose yourself run rabbit run like those
these these days Evan M makes the music
only for that angry white guy in his
truck music someone in a parking lot
music you want to have to fight even
pick their own music well sometimes you
just wonder if that was picked for them
but then sometimes you see the fighter
just walking down the aisle while
mouthing the words to the song and [ __ ]
it's funny to see that well let me ask
you this real quick yeah if you you pick
a song which we've discussed about like
what song you would come out to yeah you
pick that song and let's say you got a
fight in six months
uh-huh do you not listen to that song
until the day of the fight or do you
listen to it every day while your
trainer or not every day you listen to
it maybe not every day but you listen to
it because you practice how you walk out
you probably pitcher in the pitcher in
the people I picture what you gonna do
with your fists at a certain beat drop
yeah all right here when you look in the
mirror have it ah yeah in the mirror
like get you [ __ ] swag then yeah yeah
I don't know I think I might not listen
to it just because I'm like the next
time I hear this song I'm gonna be ready
to punch a [ __ ] in his face I
don't I don't want to associate that
song with anything else but almost in a
weird this is what a comic [ __ ] I am
but like almost how I do with [ __ ]
Anderson Parks yes Lord album cuz I
listen to it when I was in Scotland
Australia now when I hear it over here
don't seem right
yeah you know cuz I just that was the
whole theme song for that
so like I really don't listen to it
since I've been back yeah so I feel like
there's just certain songs that have to
be like compartmentalize for me like
this is a song this is like that is yeah
this is for that dude I know who I'm
fighting I know what his style is I'm
watching this I'd like this is when I
hear this song I'm gonna click over and
I'm gonna go away and be in a different
person for three rounds and I'm a huge
[ __ ] so yeah I wouldn't do any of that
but in theory how often you think
Cowboys Cerrone listens to cowboy by Kid
Rock yeah I hope never cuz it fits
that's all yeah watching him walk out
cowboy and okay I'm good on hearing that
song and so the next cowboy Cerrone
fight yeah I don't need to be perfect
when he was perfect like yeah cowboy but
do you think he'd just be chillin at the
Korea with that [ __ ] on repeat he can't
trying on different hats sighs I mean
the you I'm sure you know yeah what's
what songs has your name be mentioned in
asthma songs we mention it my name only
uh Donald Glover song le s uh-huh he
said Hannibal came to with a handle of
Jameson yeah so it's like how often do
you listen it's like I'm some weird so I
would never listen to happy like holy
[ __ ] that's dope and I'd never listen to
it again yeah like do you listen to a
Stiller uh I listen to it a little while
ago uh-huh
I don't know I think somebody mentioned
it to me and that kind of made me listen
so but I don't listen to it that off
yeah but I listened to my walk out music
before shows to get hyped at the hotel
yeah yeah so you listen to that before
you get to the that's though yeah I mean
when I you know like even walk if I'm
walking to the venue and I got
headphones I listened instead of walk
out music yeah that's dope yeah I can
see that I can see it nice so L got to
hear this story because we travel a lot
sometimes with weed yeah and you said
something happened to you at the airport
yeah I first of all miss my
missed the first flight on Sunday just
on some old the second time I'm Robin
Waite from Denver
yeah miss my second second trip in a row
wait first of all what were you guys
doing in Denver
what's a UFC okay yeah okay okay okay
and so me and HP kicked it went to my
homey B's you shout out to beat you and
the little curry shop go check him out
we stopped we went to weed shop kicked
it and you know I don't know we only run
what happen that night but in the
morning up and you know I got my bag
everything's packed get to the airport
and I had like four weed pills that you
would give me yeah and so but they were
loose and I had them in my in the little
drug pocket
yeah and you know sounds like it's
probably fine HBO as always I go though
the park is fine I'll check I was like
you even got a bit about the fifth pot
yeah I do I share knowledge pocket on
your jeans it doesn't show up on the
body scanner yeah yeah
so being nervous is fair so I had I was
already turnt up so I was like it's just
we don't go for so I took three out of
four weed pills which I know it's a lot
especially yeah talk about that later
I was just so nervous and I was like I
should have thrown away I just didn't
know I threw it away in my mouth yeah
threw it away but in my mouth son yeah
so I go through security like I always
do
through the little hole the thing you
know yeah and uh so I'll come on and do
is you know like I always I always go
you got we got a mind launch John cuz I
had surgery on my shoulders over my
soldier my shoulder always shows up yeah
and so you got metal in your shoulder
yeah I don't know if it's metal but I
had surge around them with whatever they
put in there to keep it fixed
yeah it goes off every sunny some screws
or some [ __ ] every city like I just walk
out and I'm already there I was like we
got a Petrova so um so I go through and
they do that thing where they like they
wipe your hands that that thing looks
like at the back of a band-aid
yeah anyway he waited they put in that
machine it looks like an old yeah that
Commodore 64 yeah yeah
he put that [ __ ] in there and that [ __ ]
made like r2d2 sound I got and I ain't
never heard not like that yeah it just
like in like he was just like his face
is like oh like he made a face and he
pushed a button and it printed out
something looking at EKGs like a like
the blips [ __ ] yeah and so he was like
you've tested positive for see cases 64
something you need to stand aside so I'm
like oh my god I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm assuming ish drugged something
yeah the one bomb juice man they do some
like hopefully it's just bomb juice is
not a better thing that was best-case
scenario me is thankfully it's Bob think
of the terrorists so so he they give me
like a second test like I'm still out
with all the people at this point they
give me a second test and put it in
another machine that [ __ ] makes the
exact same [ __ ] noise like yeah so
I'm like [ __ ] yeah and I'm just thinking
I'm like you know you start doing that
math like yo do I have anything my bag
did I put a joint name from the thing
yeah and so another security guard
another TSA do comes out there's three
dudes next to me at this point Jesus in
their life your highest [ __ ] pills
kicked in yes
they kicked NFS [ __ ] because the line
was like 40 minutes
oh so paranoia was going slow get that
pre check my new on American I was on
spirit on a shame trip home Oh I
reckoned out there so like no T the
spirit I don't [ __ ] preach XP really
got wheels on their planes no so so my
shits kicking in but I'm like trying to
be knowing because I'm like if you look
like you're freaking out and they're
still trying to make small talk with me
and I'm like I saying [ __ ]
lawyer cuz like lawyers the next like
dude I'm like oh [ __ ]
so another dude comes over he's like yo
come with me and I go into the room
hobby oh they put me in the white room
shut the door
three these [ __ ] are putting on
blue rubber gloves like I'm gonna bend
still a movie like like with a snap in
tsa agents are different sizes hearsay
agents ain't no one saying [ __ ] like no
one's talking no one's saying oh well
here's what we're doing next week and
dude they're in my back yo they're in my
bag the way like the feds would go
through your bra yeah they took my arm
they're swap they're wiping everything
down with that bomb juice detector
whatever I want weed or whatever this is
text you know I knew I only had that one
we pills floating around loose in my bag
is still in my bag but that was all that
was in there but they were wiping [ __ ]
down and like they took my money clip my
silver money clip with all my cards and
started wiping that [ __ ] down I was like
don't touch that sag card it's like that
wait so yeah so they're like wiping [ __ ]
down I don't office for drugs or bomb
juice but they went off they wiped down
my toothbrush
it swap the ends of my bag everything
and they were like are we're gonna get
you on your way and just like but the
whole thing took like like they were in
my bag by 25 minutes do they like body
cam definitely looking for bombs and
[ __ ] they looking for drugs because it's
the Denver to Cali trip well if they
were yeah California where you gonna do
yeah I I have people freak out like say
to me like oh man like what about the
dogs it's just like dude if these dogs
were trained to bark at weed every time
like the whole the dogs would just be
barking all the time they're everywhere
you know we people [ __ ] go to the
airport high or just smoke and then go
to get you don't I'm saying like yeah
they're not trained to smell drugs
they're trained to smell bomb here's my
only test today is when I went this last
year when I had to go but do you know I
had to go back to back when we went to
I'll show you I came back from Scotland
on the 28th had to meet y'all in
Australia on 29th yeah and so I went to
TS
international customs twice yeah and
both times it was the same [ __ ] dog
and both times that dog was up in my
[ __ ] yo because when you're walking
through that that chain that steak kind
of yeah that's dude they have the the
the dude just walks in between Allah
yeah yeah yeah and to the point where
one time the first time I went through
when I was going to Scotland like the
dog was on me and then it was on this
thick ass white girl behind me and she
like is all she said to me like because
the dog was like on both of us and like
we walk like five feet ahead and she
just goes that dog was all up in my [ __ ]
that's all she said to me yeah but like
them dogs like on a show so I don't know
what that dog was not treating this the
way three to other people's everybody's
like all dude the airport
you could go because you know Babylon so
I was like dude I travel week I'm like
dude these things ain't really playing
out there dog I'm kind of nervous
International is different though I
think that know if that dog was up in my
[ __ ] yeah
I was trying to like be normal cuz I
didn't have anything but I was like I
felt like if I had had some likes we'd
Swedish redfish like nobody got me
really yeah yo that dog was up much but
then what they say you can't leave with
this you can only eat this here what did
I what's the thing they just make you
throw it out I think they just draw if
it's like a minimal amount of weed you
travel out of Denver and that gonna
freak out as they put it in a trash is
legal in Cali - I feel like Debra would
shut down if they actually were trying
to like or the airport would shut down
if they're actually trying to enforce
those here's my only counter to that is
that airports are federal property so
that's like you have a weed in court or
on us like at the post office like
that's our gun at the post office yeah
that's why you get in a lot of trouble
that that [ __ ] is it's federal property
and so like that's why everybody's like
well I'm going from LA to Portland and
sleeker both places when you get to the
airport it's you might as well be at the
US Embassy like that [ __ ] that shit's
like federal property so you can't be
[ __ ] around and all those thing about
all how many cool last TSA agents is you
like oh just a runaway then
[ __ ] want to make an example
out of
yeah you know I'm saying it all it takes
is one dude you like five red fish with
weed in them that could be distribution
when you get to you know all it takes is
one but here's the thing I know if your
life up yo yeah but here's the thing I
know so many people that have done it so
many times with just like just [ __ ]
irresponsible amounts of weed I've heard
of you know friends like there's like
yeah it's I got 4 ounces of it throw
with my carry out and came through it's
like all good like yeah that
[ __ ] crazy yeah yeah I'm so ever
that end of it and then the other end
like yes I pre rolled it and I [ __ ]
sealed it and put it in a shampoo bottle
like people that are really precautious
but I've never heard of anyone getting
caught up for it never not once I've
never heard stories yeah so I would say
my advice is be careful but uh or if
you're gonna do it just be extra careful
don't just like they're all [ __ ]
pound in your luggage yeah yes lad
slather it in pepto slather it in
pepto-bismol and they won't be nary the
whys let me let me tell y'all why both
y'all need kids like here's my advice on
how to throw a curve ball
you said here's my advice about how to
get drugs today y'all need to be
influencing young minds I don't I always
feel like they can keep the things see
through the pepto cuz it's liquid like
if there's a joint floating in there I
don't I don't know if that's a system I
did do you be trying to look into the
scanner to see like what they see like
when you got a piece what does that look
like to them yeah just shapes man no I
have a friend I have a friend that works
D he says basically just tell them
between organic and inorganic matter and
then on top of that
mostly what they're looking for is
liquids yeah whatever it's like the weed
will probably look like just like a bag
of [ __ ] you know like you know
whatever like hey or whatever the [ __ ]
but you know they're gonna Wyoming well
like which is some kind of organic
matter it just looks like that might be
a bag of nuts or whatever it just comes
up like that it's not gonna like be like
this is weed but yeah if there's lit
thats what they're looking for is the
liquid like dog I [ __ ] I have tons
and tons of electronic equipment that I
bring through all the time right it
looks crazy it's just a bag full of
[ __ ] wires wires all kinds of [ __ ]
and one out of like ten times they
actually stop and say this looks weird
let me look at it but it looks crazy
because it's just all this metal and
wires right on zan yeah but if I have
one bottle of water it's like everyone
freaks out and I gotta do the bomb test
and I actually did test positive before
I've been through what you're talking
about before and yet they but I was like
clean I don't have anything on me swab
my hands same thing they brought me into
the back room no they took you in a room
yeah yeah yeah but he was like cuz I was
like I told him straight up I'm like
look dude I'm already late for my flight
I'm like whatever this is I'm like I'm
clean I don't know why and he explained
to me he's like there's certain kind of
hand sanitizers that set it off for some
reason or certain kind of like lotions
or creams that people use yeah but like
I don't know like yeah I guess they got
is the same components it started with
one dude and it ended up with three and
like it seemed like your dude was
talking to you yeah he was coolest my
dude try to say like one little thing
and first of all I was like I'm not
going for any oke - I'm like I'm gonna
say a word to this [ __ ]
yeah then like it just kept dudes just
kept coming over and they were sterner
and sterner every dude would come over
and just be like no love not like hey
sorry about the delay sir they were just
like no worries they're like yeah what
up oh it might have been like a higher I
don't know how those weren't yeah it
might have been like a high threat or
something like that you might have been
it like you know from amber to red or
some [ __ ] maybe yeah and the [ __ ] up
thing was you ever seen like when the
line gets really long so they'll let
people go through that fake-ass metal
detector they have it like middle
schools yeah only for Glocks you know
saying they like oh yeah now we're
blocked up or everybody goes yeah dude
they're letting everything they stopped
that [ __ ] with me and made me go through
the [ __ ] hole the thing Oh first
[ __ ] - dude that noise that
shaking [ __ ] I'll be washing my
hands though now yeah I'm gonna get a
good ol like a surgeon hand washing
floor go to that [ __ ] that might be the
[ __ ] that's setting it off though that's
the thing you don't know it's the
chemicals in certain hand washes or
sanitizers or lotions that's what that's
that's what the guy was telling me he's
like I'm sure it's not that I'm sorry
for the delay
he's like certain hand sanitizers and I
talked about this in my stand-up if it
is bomb juice on my hands where do we go
from there yeah you just intense
question to me what if I don't want to
talk about bombs I just have residue on
my hands where did where do we go from
there well that's probably why he went
through all your [ __ ] to make sure that
there wasn't a bomb in there oh I hate
sometimes they'll go through all your
[ __ ] like because my bag is a mess yeah
and so I guess sometimes they'll look
through it and it's just chaos so do we
need to do a bag check and then they'll
go through like oh it was just this book
yeah they unpack all of my [ __ ] and then
and then anything like you go you
all right go ahead and like not move
okay you took all that stuff out you
fact that [ __ ] back put my hands on my
hips like a suburban debt and watch them
pack my bag back go I did you talk about
your magazine I just like telling you I
know you have you ever seen Hannibal
reached in his pocket and pulled some
[ __ ] out like Hannibal it's like
driver's license is just loose like not
attached to anything bro I was just
saying
Hannibal spot and he's got like this
armoire thing in his living here
I know yeah it was like he opens it up
real quick it's just like DVDs VHS tapes
in just a bunch like a mountain of
crumpled up dollar
it's like dice money it's a 74 cents
it's it's 314 dollars and 74 cents when
I reach for my money clip is like
because sometimes it's getting old like
them the bills will come out I can't you
feel that
and it's weird you know saying [ __ ] it
just has I crumpled up jungle of random
lost and found been in your pockets I
don't know man I don't know what's wrong
I'm surprised you don't like end up
washing your driver's license all the
time it's [ __ ] like that just like
leaving it washing it because well I
wear the same jeans all the time yes but
you know what that weird happened I get
a tweet oh maybe I shouldn't say this
but I get a tweet saying hey uh
oh I found your ID I found your license
and they sent me a picture of the
license they blocked my license number
out an address
my parents address and then i DM them
and said where'd you find it it's how we
found it in the air B&B with the arcade
game did they have any dressers it was
under like the coffee table or something
so I got to clean it out from when I
stayed there most recently that's the
cleaning lady didn't get so now I'm like
what is my move all right I'm like do I
say hey that's mine cuz now I feel like
it's like I left my [ __ ] in my place
doesn't that really my place yeah what
do you do after that cuz you I don't
want cuz I don't wanna say it's my spot
cuz I don't know how they're gonna react
to that Instagram it oh it's nice of
them to let you know because they could
have just kept it as a souvenir as far
as my birthday but um and I think they
did that so I asked him uh so I hit up
the property manager to say that to get
that from them and then I told them to
leave it and then they didn't leave it
they didn't leave it and see I would
have sent a DM that said hey leave it on
the stove and also don't [ __ ] in my bed
yeah yeah that's what that's the thing
where I'm not sure about that yet yeah
you don't want to let people yeah cuz
the [ __ ] are first of all they
left a mess which is fine I actually
wanted to uh black dude cuz he was
here's why cuz he was one thing I read
is that you're never supposed to let
people from the city the same city Oh
Brent and I saw a Chicago and I was like
nope I know what you're up to cuz I know
what type of [ __ ] I be up yeah just
trying to parties yeah but yeah I sound
like a hypocrite though uh-huh no don't
cuz I'm like okay I get it I saw what
was happening I could have blocked it
but anyways
[ __ ] Oh me a driver's license
yo dude did you ever talk about the
paint
doggone Peyton did you get that [ __ ]
back the what the Donkey Kong Chicago
pain nope I don't know what that is
they have you talked about it on the
podcast no this is the first podcast
somebody stole one of the paintings from
the first floor and please it was such a
cool it was it was a Chicago it was
Tony's idea Chicago map of on the
neighborhood of the neighborhoods but in
the style of Mario or Donkey Kong's
really cold get another one
but it's missing but then it was frame 2
by the way it wasn't just there was rain
yeah oh yeah you've seen so but here's
the thing so the the person that was in
there she said she saw it she was like
maybe it fell behind the dresser or
whatever it's weird for a big piece of
art to do that mm-hmm and she says she
didn't find it so like who did it so now
it leaves the property manager or the
cleaning lady cuz I wrote the lady a
gimmick are you serious drop by and she
seemed pretty indignant about me so
either she was really standing on her
life well she didn't do it but it's just
a big-ass thing like wow it was like a
20 by 30 if not bigger and that girl did
not live in Chicago she did not live in
Chicago I'll tell you why I believe her
cuz like I remember you read her
response to me over the phone you know
it's like I believe her and also because
I was at my homeboys crib in New York
that I got my dog from the beloved Laila
and he has a framed photo of her when
she was a little girl huh and I couldn't
even take him with me it's like I really
that of anything yeah that's how much of
a [ __ ] it is to steal something that's
framed yeah and take it yeah that's what
she said it's like I went through two
airports you think I'm Sochi so pedaling
with the property manager just takes
something just and just try to put it on
a guest wouldn't cost that much to ship
it though you'd have if somebody really
you know that it was a dope but if
you're not from around here but the
cleaning lady like it's a [ __ ]
mystery
yeah and also if you don't live in
Chicago
you know from Chicago the neighborhood's
been making it'd be like you stealing a
frame thing from [ __ ] downtown
Baltimore
yeah in heaven in la Chicago is cooler
than Baltimore though but also also I
was hanging with my cousin we were on a
road trip
and we is some hotel in Mississippi he
stole one of those JD Power wards like a
Courtyard Marriott it but it's a New
Orleans we'd had that on the table he
will be asking about it and make up a
story based around yeah you know we are
gonna celebrate
what if that's all you own like you
weren't even a businessman you there's
no one Marriott Courtyard in Mississippi
man drinking mimosas celebrating this
awesome win oh yeah that's pretty funny
but yeah yes so it's uh I don't know it
bothers me it's not the money it's a
real mystery man it's the mystery that
but it's not it being like some towels
missing or something that easily yeah
you know a [ __ ] the even yeah you
know some some soap or something like
that or even a record yeah or DVD some
big ass on the wall print yeah
what's mean like it's not even like you
got a plan out you can't just be like
it's like I'm doing this quick you have
to okay and then I'm gonna could you the
way you even walk with it you can't even
be discreet right yeah you're hearing
something out of it and honestly if you
can't just throw that in your bag I
don't want to give anybody any thoughts
but if you were gonna steal something
out of those units like there's way dope
or [ __ ] steal so if you're gonna do that
like there be doper paintings to steal I
don't know my which I also don't steal
the paintings anybody listen also we
might think this might just be us
venting no but like what's the so what's
the proper protocol if someone leaves
something behind at your spot if they
leave it behind
yeah and they and say someone left an
expensive watch at your place right yeah
and they swear that they left it at your
place but it's nowhere to be found
right let's say it's another mysterious
missing maybe you got a poltergeist
living at your place no no what's the
protocol for that like who's responsible
for that what yes I don't know if we
don't find it that day yeah that's sorry
that's it a game cuz I can't confirm
their watch you have to confirm my place
in pictures on the wall I can confirm
yeah yeah before and afters of of that
yeah I don't I mean if somebody lose
they what my photos little [ __ ] every
day
Oh do my bit in hotels
yeah yeah how many thousands of dollars
in chargers everything my brother stayed
at a down at a hotel in downtown Chicago
once and him and his girlfriend came he
came home one night and he drank too
much but he had just bought this really
nice new watch
and it was vomiting right he was real
sick and he was vomiting so he took he
remembers taking the watch off and
putting it on the bedside thing and then
just continued vomiting and vomiting and
there's vomit everywhere now and so they
called front desk to get someone up to
cleaner hey what's up I can't hold my
liquor can you help yeah pretty much
so he's in there she's like his girls
like trying to help him out whatever and
this lady was just kind of I don't know
if it's a lady or a guy or whatever is
someone in there I was cleaning up but
help him clean and there was in the
obvious main area bedroom area whatever
and then going back and forth and then
they left and then they woke up the next
morning and the watch was gone yeah
so it's questionable because I'm like
you were drunk bro like anything could
happen you could have just took me but
how many times does it happened like a
grown-ass man is wearing a watch and
he's too drunk and it falls off his hand
like your watch stays on yeah you know
no man and they searched they tore up
the room looking for this watch and they
couldn't find anything it's like a I
would probably say it was like a three
four thousand dollar watch so it wasn't
a cheap watch you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah and it's a it was an obviously
valuable watch but how do you know what
I'm saying ladies prove it really you
prove it like this [ __ ] came up
that's all I know unless you want to
have cameras it cuz that's the thing
well you gotta if you wanna use that
cameras that's it and so that's it but
we don't have cameras in the rooms I'm
saying for your own hotel room if you
want to have your own camera yeah
that's your right to have that foot
whenever housekeeping is in there or
some [ __ ] I'm you know you should you
can do like teddy bear cameras and
like that I mean giant cowboy hat a pack
of crayons a lens I mean but that's got
to be a crazy come up like every day
people checking out hotel rooms I'll
leave and [ __ ] every day yeah you got to
be coming up on chargers yeah watches
don't I just left my Empire my brand new
air air pods in Charleston but they were
cool as [ __ ]
well mostly because they didn't know
when it was there like we was wondering
what the hell these things were so I got
him back there there's something back to
me on the technology front yeah when I
was just in Charlotte yeah I came down
and get pick up my order from post maze
and there were people that were getting
on the elevator across from me when I
was stepping off and then they were
still in that same one I don't know how
this goes up to 16 cuz we it's not
working anyway and then he asked me like
I worked it like but he's just you know
yeah it's three of them in there - yeah
goes up to 16 elevators whatever man all
they do I get on the other side - dude
Gasol with me and he didn't realize it
was an elevator where you had to touch
it yeah can with the key you had to do
to touch key and I can I get one person
that give me but I liked it out of that
group of three three different separate
people from separate worlds didn't
figure out the taptic key and so I think
we ended up he was on my floor Oh got
off a foot and he was like huh he talked
about he was like man this big city
stuff man like this big city stuff Oh
touching that keypad with the big city
what what happened a regular case so
he probably wants the old-school keys
were like they reach and I got a set of
like to master why can't we use them
when we settle disputes with ten paces
and turn around you know but there is
some charm to like when you do find a
spot that like decided to keep the whole
key system
[ __ ] that [ __ ] cuz then they charge you
a hundred if that's true regular key but
I hate that but like with Reynolds I
hate that [ __ ] push the start
[ __ ] I like turning the key start
the car
you know what I'm saying like I'm
old-school like that lady
I like push to start even though I don't
peel out yeah but if you if you did push
the start will be good for peeling out
what do you like like getting out of
there fast
I think push to start no because with
the key like I feel like you could feel
the car better when you when you have
the crank the kids like it you know what
I'm saying yeah when you put it's a
[ __ ] button like the button kind of
takes away like the feeling of driving
an automobile that makes that sound
crazy al I get when you cover from good
I like to push to start I think it's I
don't think rappers should brag about it
anymore
I don't think grabbers I push to start
like oh it's possibly a Nissan Altima
soda sponsored by squarespace.com make a
website get to it you have a business
are you an artist do you have a
restaurant they make it very easy for
you go to spread spray that yeah you go
mode you Hannibal sorry
now squarespace.com promo code Hannibal
all right and we gets back to us talking
about [ __ ] put it back put the podcasts
back on now
Pillman back today these fights in
Kansas City look crazy it was a great
event I think I'm a sponsor a fighter
yeah I am a sponsor a Invicta MMA
fighter how do you sponsor a fighter you
well you can reach out to them directly
or you could yeah I think that's it you
reach out directly and say hey I have
this can you do this and then I'll go
haggle haggle and you figure it out once
so once you sponsor your fighter what
are they gonna what is what are they
gonna well I'm thinking I mean look at
when the event is but I'm thinking just
a custom-designed outfit just all of my
face and the podcast just really yeah
yeah I thought you just have your name
on the back and just like if you get
knocked out can fall forward that's the
one thing is that if I sponsor fighter
to get they [ __ ] smashed in what if it's
like a horrific beating and it like gets
replayed in just you but is it a buddy
it's like that like funny hose that bad
but I think it works either way yeah
exactly you win either way man what is
what like by some stroke of bad luck
all the fighters I sponsored would knock
that would be a great that would be
great for you because then people would
watch your fights or your sponsored
fights just to see the other person win
every time it could be interesting but
yeah I think I definitely I wanna
sponsor one I don't see every coat what
the limitations are what the specifics
are in the design how much can I do I
think it's I think the main idea is you
always have these left-field ideas I
love it that 100 tell al about your art
center that's a great idea
talking about that the other day oh I
don't want to
get into that and then I don't want to
make that to public yet because it's
very good actually you know what cuz if
you talk about stuff then it kind of
brings the right people to you sometimes
yeah
so I want to have a Art Center on the
west side of Chicago it's not a lot of
stuff over there so something I mean
I'll figure out what the full curriculum
and system is was something like with
you know writing classes improv classes
after school programs music [ __ ] like
that and different events but just
something constant on the west side like
went by and I found a site that's close
to what my parents house is so still
like this is an early idea of what is
something I want to do so if anybody has
history experience starting stuff like
that nonprofits whatever you have books
or anything you want to write you know
send them to the hands of Rambla
gmail.com and I want your help
Thanks you know would be dope as if like
eventually this expanded into like your
own Hannibal Burres arts college that's
my own College that'd be dope is [ __ ]
bro that'd be crazy but I mean you got
to start somewhere
and I mean an Arts Center is a perfect
place to start like I said grace you
know I just want to just have some where
people can have easy access to you know
just trying out some [ __ ] just right
okay I can do this right here yeah block
away just walk so we'll see how it goes
it's a nice it's the craziest office
building right by my parent's house it's
a place actually a place I used to get
my hair cut as a kid is in that bill and
yeah so we gonna see if it goes through
smoothly man I like that college idea
just because like I wanted to get to be
just so successful that it just becomes
like part of the vernacular
yeah just some people's like dude I got
a year and a half and get that Burruss
about a four year you know
yeah how many successful [ __ ]
you know that was just like yeah my goal
is to eventually start a college you
know like that's nobody well there's a
lot of work I mean I don't think nah be
that means personally I mean you know I
never understand I mean it seems like
the for-profit colleges are like now
like that's the [ __ ] Trump was on yeah
that was another thing we talked about
not like to make it not for profit or
whatever you but I think it's hard this
is the NPR the day and I heard they like
certain a non profit is hard as [ __ ]
yeah so I don't even know how to [ __ ]
you do that but it's harder than
starting a for-profit anything well you
cuz you gotta convince [ __ ]
yeah and on some slams I think yeah like
the taxes and [ __ ] it's just like I
think so many people took advantage of
not-for-profit and made its yeah yeah
you can be like I'm not for profit
what's my salary nine hundred thousand
dollars a year
I always thought that was weekly use
because that's one thing now is my issue
would donate into stuff sometimes yeah
is this going directly to people or is
this going like forty percent going to
your CEOs house whoever runs it and then
twenty percent I don't want none of my
[ __ ] when I donate to a cause I don't
none of my [ __ ] going to office supplies
that you need office supplies I just
don't going towards that especially with
office supplies are like to the good
[ __ ] and and I want to talk [ __ ] about
the United Way I mean I've heard and
some not great things but I don't know
so I won't say anything I mean oh you
know I'm suing it still good donate but
it just seems like whenever you have a a
profit non for profit that's got people
work for the United Way provide twenty
thousand thirty that like I don't know
uh probably a lot yeah you know I'm
saying like you know you that means that
you're having a year and gallows and
vacations and retreats it's like
couldn't that dough be like just take
that twenty and handed to a kid I got a
hard twenty great rather than like
filtering it to however many
[ __ ] CEOs and vice like
yes sir yeah I'm already I don't know if
I'm built to be asking people for money
- hey can I uh you know I got this going
on and uh I guess somebody else would do
it on my behalf
but I still be doing it you wouldn't
need you would just you can just do you
have another famous friends where you
could do the kind of [ __ ] we're like you
know whatever you just gives people
together but you charge 200 bucks a
ticket but you go all of it goes - yeah
aníbal yeah
Burress the Leadership Academy kind of
[ __ ] yeah and so like people are paying
you but you know you just it just goes
straight to straight into a fund yeah
you know I think I think that's the
thing the easier thing where I've been
taking donations cuz then once you start
having like well this is my CEO and this
is my CFO and then she's got an
assistant and someone so good and then
she needs to drive her here and business
expenses taking people to dinner wine
and dine it's just like now you're
getting into yeah [ __ ] I don't want to
do I was like that that Jeff gig you did
was it Jeff
the juf yeah isn't that wasn't that the
same thing basically it was just like a
big fancy event or so yearly event that
they do yeah pretty much the same thing
though right what it's like a
non-for-profit thing making me sound
great I don't know what I don't know
what it was I know thank you you're
inviting me to this woman's Avenger
thank you so much the wire payment I'm
yo okay I feel like I'm people are
getting off track but I kind of feel
like I like it cuz it's a trilogy of
this Kansas City story it deserves to be
in pieces like in it like people listen
to like was it
yeah trust me I'm on it y'all I remember
so we watch the fights to fight it was
amazing I can't
and this isn't that and I just if you
live in that area if you like traveling
to do [ __ ] Kansas City
Invicta it's a fun time it's great
entertainment $35 you right up in that
[ __ ] you can yell and coach if you want
to that's what I learnt in MMA even at
the UFC events that'll be huge if you
project you can invite top to the
fighter you can say hey move young up
got ya you gotta help escape you can
just yell that [ __ ] and everybody can
hear you and they can hear you they
decide whether they want to listen that
but they hear that [ __ ] need to start
yelling at the fighters that I bet
against trying to stop this college man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if you win this fight five Westside kids
can't learn drugs lose for the Arts yeah
let me ask you this man
yeah if somebody's listening and they
like I've never been to a fight before
yeah why would you tell them why do they
need to go to a live boxing MMA
tell me cuz I haven't been doing them a
fight ever it's intense man for because
you don't know when it you know boxers
you know you got your knockout boxers
and and [ __ ] get stopped but a lot of
times it's a sport at the it a go to the
in it well it's just gladiator [ __ ] and
then it could end at any time a lot of
them do not go to the decision today
negative for three rounds and that's
what makes it crazy especially as a
estimate of Gamble's on sports and the
rush I get from it but wait this
Invictus [ __ ] though it was it was no
headgear not no padding not that right
just gloves in Victor's just like I mean
as far as the rules is loves in Cup UFC
nope
no cup is Invicta in victors all women
oh that's right sorry somebody's using a
cups they're getting test it right out
to the face yeah but watching that
[Laughter]
you're immediately here immediate to
positive steroids testers you so I mean
it's um yeah some interesting-looking
fighters that have come out and Victor
yeah but it with a football game or
basketball game basketball game got a go
no matter what me even if the outcome is
decided via blowout early in the third
quarter it still has to play out four
quarters 12 minutes football the same
way my husband be smashed 42 nothing at
halftime we still have to play out that
time fighting that [ __ ] might just be
done in 13 seconds and I've seen it well
somebody just might get clocked and they
just got clocked and they [ __ ] spent
their they spent months and then just
got clocked months spent months training
and there's like a little luck involved
like this guy just caught them right at
the right time I don't know if his luck
I'm just saying though some fights like
the guys prepared everything's good and
this guy just got that one kick to the
neck at the right spot right time do you
think McGregor Aldo was luck uh I think
there was a little bit of luck involved
in that like way counter yeah it was
like yeah ain't nobody ever caught him
like that yeah I think maybe that one
but you know other fight when it's like
going like a couple rounds and then
they're tiring each other out and and it
becomes like a stamina is
yeah obviously like somebody's got the
edge on someone else but like in the
first 15 seconds there's got to be some
luck involved yeah unless you're getting
your ass kicked like Ronda Rousey just I
mean we all know she was going down
right away yeah well yeah that's what I
mean is this not the lucky fact that was
just that the timing isn't that said
West it probably you know I don't know
what percentage it is that get but I
think I was guess at least 40 to 50
percent of fights don't go to the cards
you know and that's what makes it really
dope especially when you bet on the
right person yeah but uh so yeah that'd
be you know you brought up something I
thought was really interesting it's like
what if you got knocked out like 15
seconds and you go back to the dressing
room go back to the hotel you sleep you
wake up the next morning you probably
feel fine and you're in great [ __ ]
shape and it's like for what you don't
say I don't think you'll feel fine after
getting knocked out like a clean like a
clean when you if you just get starched
I don't talking about you get beat up
over the course of three rounds yeah but
it's like you got you're looking when
you get knocked out your brain have you
been not been smashed I've been close to
knocked out there's actually a funny
story I'll tell you but when you're
getting knocked out your brain is
hitting the side of your [ __ ] skull
yeah you're right and it's just it's
getting splattered like boom and then
like you don't know like your body's
like I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on and you're out like you cannot feel
good after that happens that's like
worse than a hangover you know have you
ever been knocked out of either one of
you ever been knocked out I've been like
cold
I've been roughed up ya know this one
time me and my homie we're in a wicker
park in Chicago and he was drunk and
just act like goddamn full so I was like
this before
uber so I'm like alright I'm just trying
to [ __ ] cuz he's talking [ __ ] to
someone blah blah whatever so I'm trying
to hail this cab so I held his cab down
and then I like he's got his shirt off
and he's like dude just shut the [ __ ] up
get his he's like beefing with some
throw him in the car and he's still
talking [ __ ] out
whatever and then this guy is coming up
to the dorm like dude this guy's drunk
I'm like you're drunk she's [ __ ] I'm
like just go away man I'm like just go
away I'm getting this guy home like calm
down
this guy's irate he's in my face and I'm
like dude just get the [ __ ] out of my
face I'm like I'm not trying to fight
you bro
and he sucker punches me damn I was
wearing a fedora to look real bad Fedora
lying face [ __ ] to the side like my
head knocked back so I'm so like I come
to like he hit me so all right I flew
back and then I come to it I was like I
didn't think he was gonna hit me at all
like I'm just like the guy in the middle
child like he just like I think he was
trying to prove something cuz his homies
were there I think he was just trying to
prove something and then I I come - he's
already booked down the street where did
where did he catch you he caught me
right on the jaw like [ __ ] right on the
jaw and then I come to like this [ __ ]
you follow you kind of stumbled not like
I stumbled back and then I was like back
up against because I was in front of the
cab I kind of like went back on the hood
a little bit yeah and I came to in the
do was down the block he was already
gone he like by the time I came to he
was gone were you like hazy all night no
no I was I mean I was drinking but I
wasn't like trash no no no I mean after
he hit you were you kind of like yeah
yeah yeah my [ __ ] was [ __ ] up and then
yeah after that I was like never get
caught like that again
yeah I started taking a bunch of martial
arts that was the beginning of my
martial boys talking [ __ ] didn't get it
at all no not at all he [ __ ] yeah he
was just like I don't even think he even
realized what I don't even think he saw
me get hit was your boy taller yeah yeah
yeah I threw his ass in the car you know
what it was this guy was the guy that
hit me was in front of this bar at the
time we remember the Blue Note yeah now
it's the Flatiron but at that time it
was the Blue Note and his boy was
working the door but he was giving
people like he was on some [ __ ] all
night cuz I remember he was giving
people [ __ ] and it's like yo do you even
work here and he was just like no boo
you know you need to calm down like he
kept likes you talking yeah he was just
being a [ __ ] dick for no reason so
like my guy was drunk but like he was
like it's like just let this guy be a
dick and like let's just go have a good
time but like my guy wouldn't let it go
he's like no this guy's being a dick for
no reason so he kept [ __ ] going back
and forth I'm like stop wasting your
time with this [ __ ] through this guy
is obviously a loser and he's trying to
start fights with people for attention
yeah you know and I'm saying and he had
his friends there and they were just
like look at this guy he's crazy he's
like the crazy guy he's probably gonna
end up in jail this is fun he's crazy
he's like that kind of a dude yeah
that's why he [ __ ] stop he wanted to
stick someone that night yeah just on
some like look at me I'm nuts yeah I did
not expect that at all
I just know the way hold up is the
question yeah I don't know if I'm a was
it a white guy so that's you know guy
was it an asian guy was it a Filipino
guy was it no Supino's or agent was it I
know
was it an Australian guy it was a black
really I'm sorry guys black it was a
black guy goddamn I'm sorry see I
thought you were gonna ask like there
must have been like some please over
they had to take the report but it's
like I saw the gun Fedor get it must
have flown so far that like I was like
like when I came to I'm like wait a
minute where's my head all I'm imagining
is my hat probably [ __ ] flew in there
I must look like an [ __ ] the best way
to hit somebody is if they're wearing a
fedora that's nice yeah
people probably saw it yeah you weren't
in the wrong
[Applause]
and my Fedora probably flipped like 25
yeah like that that's not that but I did
like seeing a dude in the fedora get
punched where where did the hateful
fedoras nothing crazy
it's like someone's seeing someone trip
with a bunch of black papers like it's
like it adds comic yeah so yeah I mean
[Music]
shouldn't a war for a door out that
things were like you always know people
lying about a story we're like no one
would add that detail the fedora do you
know that [ __ ] happens just like that oh
man that was word-for-word and y'all
know me I could just see that being me
because I'm always do like all right
just let's go home and I could just do I
got a girl with him though because he
got cuz I was just trying to break it up
and I'm like why are you at the club I
feel like I'm when it's over yeah I'm
like dude just go over there
this guy's in the cab I'm like this it's
over man I'm like leave it alone so I
got a little lob with them but not
definitely not on some like my hands
were out like this because I'm just like
trying to you know get them apart and
then he's like you know what [ __ ] that
and he just punches me in the face
somebody had to get it he was the
closest one yeah yes to the left side
give that to your boy never happened to
me again though yeah never ever again
when I'm on I want to just apologize for
for - that guy up I was there the Bulls
cap and I was cheering him on see that
guy in the fedora
one question for you sonic yeah and I'm
sure Hannah bleep rhymes is to mate
talking about training a little bit too
um how would you how with your training
now have would you deal with that exact
same circumstance is different because
like I can see how vulnerable you are
with your arms extended in your chin
yeah exposed so like how do you get your
boy in the cab or like protect your neck
well it's easy wouldn't it's a very
simple thing most of the time I think
it's like a human instinct when you're
squaring up with somebody hands seem to
go down and chest seems to come out this
might be like some natural ape [ __ ] that
we do but you notice when more focused
hands are down face neck everything is
vulnerable than the whole the most
important part of your body the
functional parts are all up here and
your hands are down here first thing you
do is just not go into a [ __ ] Duke
stance right but like just [ __ ] touch
your chin or just like have your hands
up like have your palms up like this and
by your face right like that's what you
mean like once you feel any kind of
thing like animosity or any kind of
hostility your hands should be up like
that's the number one thing then that's
why they like the trainers say your
hands always you always got to be a
guard whatever yada yada that's what you
do and then if something happens at
least you're pretty no matter how strong
the guy is at least you're prepared to
like protect yourself the where I had
where my mistake was that night was that
my hands were just like outstretched yes
you know but in reality I should have
had my hand one hand in front of me one
hand wherever to control the situation
right trying to get your boy in the cab
yeah yes I would never think I wouldn't
wouldn't have been able to he might have
grace you were not ready what a great
not to tag me like the way he tagged me
right on yeah so it's just about being
aware is about being prepared so it's
like that's part of training is just
like you know doing that over and over
with like a partner like going back and
forth like training with your hands up
but that's the main thing is that just I
mean it's a simple thing that makes
sense to have hands down here I have
your
up here that's it you know really even
if you can't fight that's gonna you know
that's gonna and if someone's kicking
your ass like how to properly cover the
vital points of your head and your
throat in whatever basis you know what
I'm saying like if you are getting your
ass kicked
how do you protect yours is not the good
attitude talk about whooping s look
sometimes somebody's gonna go I want to
talk about whatever it is you're gonna
get out matched everybody's gonna get
their note that mean everybody know what
if you went to a training fight I wish I
knew MMA I wish I knew I had some
training I feel like you're close to
getting into that [ __ ] though and saying
I wish I had some training in Kansas
City back to the Kansas City story this
is great there's like a theme to this so
we go see the fights it's a good time
yeah we decide to go out for a little
bit man we mean this this young lady
having a good time Kansas City little
day at this particular night because
they were expecting ice storms oh yeah
and so we go to the main bar district go
to a couple spots this is low it's a
little dip we walk into this one spot it
was packed but it was just it was the
night before the Chiefs play the
Steelers uh-huh and so I walked in and
then they were everybody in the front of
the bar
[Music]
Oh and I'm like [ __ ] no and I turned
right around and we ended up at this
other bar and we're having a good time
they were playing hip-hop it was a good
chill vibe it was it was weird cuz it
was I remember the dance floor being
sparse but everybody was active in a
different way it was my father's were
doing a bunch of different types of
dance to the same beat the visual
somebody's on that [ __ ] breakdancing
somebody was like tango in like a couple
you know ironically dance yes future
like let's dance like future is a love
song yes we're learning [ __ ] and if
somebody was doing some white eyes white
ass like side beside like speed skating
there's two step type [ __ ] it was just
visually brilliant I remember it was
with some dudes just like snapchatting
themselves over in the corner not on the
dance level that's far from the bar just
like snapchatting like what are you I
get whatever I have fun that's 15 people
here like what are you saying that
whatever but I just remember you know
having a good time we're having some
drinks a couple drinks we end up kicking
in there for a couple of hours they
started playing shy town [ __ ] cuz I
wanna do they play like do or die
post ilpo pimpin the sequel Sumerian
DJ's don't really play that [ __ ] play
cruiser conflict hey remember the deeds
they did a blend from this who's old
girl from Detroit
- low Dead's loaf I don't know if it's
her summit let's just be honest yeah
that's be real and the deeds they went
from it let's just be real Blin it's a
Jake oh that's track we say first things
first recipes uncle feels right yeah for
real so you hate how dope of a line is
that the start a song yeah I really like
that's the only father I really knew I
was like I got chills
and coming real yeah yeah but it was
like crazy specific blends and it was I
just said all those details just
established that I wasn't that faded but
I Hannibal I've seen you have you have
crazy like black out memory because I've
seen you hammered blacked out but still
you remember [ __ ] but this would anyways
go ahead anyway okay well you plus or
minus for walking in there
- oh sure you're fine yeah - I was maybe
at one or two walking in there and had
maybe three in there three for body it
so that's and that's over the course of
a couple hours and that's not so is like
so that was a lie like your measurement
question that was very precise yeah this
is this [ __ ] is one of the craziest
didn't I get crazy so yeah I go to the
bar this is you know this is about
Jewish now I think the bar close at
close to three is getting closer to what
and at some point oh girl she had had
another level she had been drinking more
than me at the other spots and drank
more at the so she was a bit lit I need
to see the progression it was just like
she went from being you know somebody I
was talking to to just being a mess up
some jellyfish just the body that I was
with and you have to take the hair up
like there wasn't no there was nothing
but screen a city or it was just like
okay I know you know me what was she
saying like Howard she took it he just
turned into jelly
I like that jellyfish I've seen yeah
that's so interesting you said it though
it was it was so I go to the bar and a
couple dudes asked him to take a picture
I take a picture with them and it was
his older black dude
he's like I recognize you you had a
familiar face before he can get the
census out of his mouth the girl when
she snatches scarf off of him and then
he kind of he reaches to grab the scarf
off her and I slap his head and say
don't touch her he's like don't touch
don't you touch me
that's my scarf and she's just kind of
like nothing like no that's her scarf
cuz I do remember at the bar before we
were bored and [ __ ] and then like I
rocked the scarf and it was like making
weird poses with it handed it to her
like we huh
it wasn't just like I seen her with the
scarf is like uh you had some tender
moments tender moments with this scarf I
remember this sounds like a hoax like
put around both your necks and took a
[ __ ] ya know about this and so he's
like no this is my scarf I walked in
with this wait how big is this dude this
dude is this maybe a little bit taller
than me skinnier dude 40 something it's
just really added me I walked in with
this scarf that's must you saw me walk
in with this [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like this
dude is and then he starts going into
some other she's I make $30 an hour bro
like here you know I'll do accents well
you're not an accent but that's it as
burnt in mine I make $30 an hour wait I
have a question
what was he I said at the beginning you
don't [ __ ] that's all railroad the
story to do that a 45 year old black
dude I'm sorry my bad it's all good man
yeah and so uh yeah make $30 an hour and
still no scarf [ __ ] you brought like
just going and he's just standing on and
it's just mine is just I'm going crazy
cuz I can't even really was he like like
like did you get the vibe that he was
ready to fight like straight up he was
talking like it was body language like
I'm
to throw it out you can tell yeah you
can tell it will we'll get more into it
cuz this is just a beginner so he's
snapping out he's snapping about this
[ __ ] oh my god I can't even really
process him being so attached to this
scarf that's not his he like it's my
scarf and then I just [ __ ] just snap
like I would yield it at all like [ __ ]
you is not your [ __ ] scar shut the
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] thief shut the [ __ ]
he's just like at the top of my [ __ ]
like I rarely do and then obviously
after I scream like that
the vibe of the bar change a little bit
dimmer sure I'd say yeah yeah I did but
he was really frustrated everybody
looking at this point or as people snap
that many people there and the way it is
it's the bar right here in the bar a
circular I think and then the dance
floor so it's and it's not that many
people there and the majority of them
are around the situation now didn't they
get him out of there and they get him
out and then I'm kind of winding down
like damn that's [ __ ] crazy I can't
believe that this dude you know really
thought that was crazy did he like I'm
trying to process it having a dream and
then dude the whole time he's still out
front in my high line like at the door
[ __ ] you like waiting [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and you just kind of just real
just angry outside like y'all just gonna
let him be here like that and then they
say you know what man sorry about that
you know just have a drink wine down you
know you let you out out to the back
call you could call the uber I'll call
that and then you can get out out back
and
that [ __ ] and I'm gonna cool man Thank
You man I just want to you know get out
of here smoothly and go to the bathroom
come back I don't know what the woman I
was with said to them or what happened
but now they think is his scarf they
turned on you they turn I don't know
what and I didn't I just went for a
quick piss I didn't take a dump but at
the time who this quick piss I come back
I don't know what she said I see they
were like that's his scarf man that's
his scarf and design audience what just
give the scarf back what we got scarves
downstairs gave it back just give it
back man I'll give her $50 if she can't
hello
just give a scarf back I'm like what it
was definitely they saw her that old
girl was hammered and was like there's
no way that's her scarf
she's scarf back oh yeah this is all
these voices crazy [ __ ] and I'm trying
to calm people down cuz I know I mean
this is her scarf I don't know what the
[ __ ] y'all talk about this is and I try
to walk up on one do like a man this
he's like no you ain't gotta walk up on
me no celebrity [ __ ] here whatever and
so didn't like you got to go Gian do
like you got to go to you to me
okay cool leaving but they I don't know
in the moment maybe I should have I'm
not leaving now this is Dora with this
[ __ ] but it was just moving so
fast they look you gotta go to my clue
listen Manny like nah we tried to talk
it out but not you you gotta get out and
what time is this probably 230 is too
tight they were closing down anyway with
their long let me chill out I want to
just chill out let [ __ ] mellow whatever
so do puts me out there and then it's
two employees out there and the crazy
person is screaming at me and that's my
[ __ ] scarf he's still going on
about you know he talking to them you
know I wouldn't lie about that [ __ ] and
then a day out there like just give them
man just give them the scarf just give
it to him and so I'm trying to talk to
her
like coz now because this dude's undying
passion and energy combined with all the
other people like you we saw him walk in
with it we saw him walk in with the nun
like did she steal the scarf I'm not
here convinced anomaly I'm like [ __ ]
I've been with her for a few hours but
she had but maybe she like future stole
that [ __ ] back and came back she went to
the future stole it from him came to the
finals kicked it what I'm like yeah and
so I'm trying to talk to her I say hey
did you
is this your scarf but she's so faded
she's just can't even even she's like
trying to not address it and say
deceased she's like oh I took the scarf
off her neck knows about the head its
own that's why the hand it's over then I
remember why was that Invicta fights
that this woman wanted to take a picture
with me and they had tweeted me the
picture
and I looked at me that they had tweeted
me the picture earlier an old girl she
was with me in a picture wearing a scarf
so I remembered that I scroll down very
sharp and then I saw a boy that worked
there like this is a picture from
earlier that's her with the scarf and
his face is drop he was like oh [ __ ] my
bad man do y'all do like my bad man the
crazy dude doesn't give him a [ __ ] cuz
he's a crazy purse yeah like okay so you
show the crazy guy the evidence and he's
still at that point any decent normal
human being be like okay there's nothing
I can say yeah yeah yeah so now I just
want to know boy does my [ __ ] and
then have to fight it or get into some
[ __ ] with a you know super drunk woman
to my side any I don't really want to do
way any [ __ ]
so they let he let me back in does now
apparently I don't have to deal with the
crazy president according it and so I
was a bit
oh you know I was feeling good and kind
of vindicated MMH I was like I want to
talk to old boy that popped off of me
and GM that put me out there no
superstar [ __ ] in here that dude that
dude the dude that dude and then [ __ ]
that dude in the GAE comes upstairs I
was like look man here's the picture of
her wearing this from earlier and he was
like I don't care you still gotta go oh
yes yeah and so that's can we put this
bar on blast please no you know I [ __ ]
them you know I actually I put them on
blast a day after on Twitter and you
know I cuz my father's have off days
what a back [ __ ] I know I tell you you
can't say no [ __ ] like don't bring
notebook things [ __ ] in huge outside
chances City Ponderosa full of people at
the end of the day you can't say [ __ ]
like that
alright man so yeah yeah and no he
didn't say get that so it wasn't like
get out of here with that it was
something in reference to me being
somewhat recognizable all I was trying
to do was kind of yeah talk to him you
know and a lower tone but they were
convinced that it was her yeah yeah that
she stole a scarf or whatever woods and
so no and so I was a little I was pissed
off the next day or the whole situation
and I tweeted angrily [ __ ] this place
but now like let's have off nice and I
don't know if they you know I mean I've
handled things poorly before and so I'm
trying to figure out you know the
situation how he thought it was his but
uh anyway they put me out do puts me out
just get out again yeah put me out there
the second time right out front would do
now maybe I should have said hey I got a
I'm not going out that door you can put
me out but put me out away from this
crazy [ __ ] but in the moment I
didn't go against it I guess I was like
whatever this is you put me out him and
so this dude is just walking alongside
me just screaming
[ __ ] you bus how far away is he from you
he's like he wanted you to hit him he
was like close could he touch you if he
had extended his arm he was he was a
little bit ahead he got close at a
couple points
you know what that situation was it was
literally him trying to get you to hit
him first
no I know that's all there was and so
he's just like [ __ ] [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and so we get to this cross street
now I ordered the car and I'm waiting
and oblivious to the stranger -
screaming [ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah you know
Hollywood [ __ ] we got money
we got lawyers and lawyers but yeah I
think he did try to bait me yeah
into hitting him cuz he didn't run up on
he just talked mad [ __ ] cuz if he was
really that mad he would have ran up on
he would have easy yeah and so the uber
comes I put I put her in and I hop in it
and then dude is just standing in front
of the car screaming just standing like
pointing [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you and
overdrive has no context for what this
is it is crazy dude is standing in front
of the car [ __ ] who were driving just
reverses because he just reverses to the
cross street that's behind the dam to
make a left there it was a cop at that
crosswalk what is going huh what are you
doing gambling that guy's crazy he was
standing in front of the car we didn't
probably need to reverse you probably
could have just did it a little bit of a
reverse and then rid of wound a guy but
yeah that mofo that's how that night
ended you know what that was that was a
five star reverse yeah that was the
first time I left a note on my review
usually I just give five stars and I
don't say anything I was like we were in
danger and
the driver was very cool under pressure
and is gonna get an uber JD Power water
lay a smooth reverse and then we got out
of it wait but you said didn't you say
that the guy is like well-known and he's
got a he's got a nickname or some
well-known for a bombing well that's
what I know he's known he's known in the
area so then I talked about well talked
about on Twitter I took them down but I
talked about the situation so then
there's people with their secondhand
accounts that's not what happened you
just you didn't well you got drunk you
didn't hold your liquor right you need
to you got you got to meet Knight Rider
no Street Fighter is his name you met
Street Fighter you just mentioned that
next bad yeah you forgot that part of
the story how this is in the reply yes
replies to my team name is Lake fighter
who like Taos that Street Fighter he's
harmless
right first of all you can't use that in
this thing it's all about him being
harmless if this my goodness screamed at
my pointing to it like stood in front of
my car at 3:00 in the morning alone by
himself
so you know but uh so yeah his nickname
is street fighter street fighter and and
yes so it was I'm wondering did what
happened did he find a scarf in the club
what he did she drop it on the street
and then he he grabbed it and then felt
connected to it well
listen let's one thing's for sure oh
girl was so drunk that she obviously
dropped it her left behind yeah he found
it and he was like it's my scarf maybe I
think if she dropped it in the club I
don't think she dropped it on the street
that's scarf but he was just so cuz
here's another thing he kept on bringing
up in back-and-forth he's like um um um
I make $25 an hour he switched it up and
points when he was yeah I can wind down
this is crazy he said 30 25 and 24
dollars per hour at the time I talked so
he also I got kids I got [ __ ] stage
three cancer
and he has some implant he kept showing
that look at this [ __ ] bro
and something sticking out of it I was
going through surround his [ __ ] oh I get
it I was trying to at one point I was
trying to reason with I was I see man I
get it I was like I get that you
struggling with and he's like I'm
struggling I kept it
I kept it pretty how much time would you
say passed from like the time that she
snatched that off his neck to the time
yo driver reverse like how much time
that had to be at least around an hour
because I was in there for a minute
he was waiting outside you let that
whole fiasco go on for an hour we should
have been the [ __ ] out of there like
well you know after when he snatched the
[ __ ] when she snatched it from him and
then he went outside it was just got
kind of a winding down period to figure
out how to avoid the [ __ ]
and then you come back out I don't know
if it was an hour cuz I know he waited
out there for a minute after like that
[ __ ] I think we chilled for about 15
after it happened and then that's when I
went to the bathroom and that's when I
came back and they had changed their
minds about the entire situation so they
turned on five minutes very crazy
situation man can't leave you can't
leave a girl by herself the state her
case that's what happen I didn't know
what it was going Tara Gator without my
permission you know that's what it's all
to the client with what yeah that's what
happened yeah yeah they got there went
straight for your client yeah they was
so we got scarves downstairs man oh man
that [ __ ] was so it was very intense and
still all over a scarf
what is his scarf represent to him do
you think that scarf light am I getting
too deep while making it into a metaphor
like my better I mean the better
question is what did the scarf mean to
you what a scarf meant to me
didn't mean anything to me so then what
was the beef about I think that scarf
meant it that was probably like I don't
know how to do was dressed yeah but it's
probably the nicest thing he owned when
he picked that scarf I don't know how
nice it was card that was you might
neither think it is a nice car from dear
might build a thrift scarf but it was
nice lifted it made him feel good yeah
probably like was like that was his
that's the thing about taste about like
if you have nothing and then you even
get a hold of like a $40 watch alright
we're like this is this is that's what
I'm saying like some people are like
clothing doesn't matter
yeah like clothing is everything I'm a
little bit in between yeah it's just
like sometimes yeah it doesn't matter
but well sometimes you find that the ill
jacket or you like so you come up on
something you're like this is the dopest
[ __ ] and here it's just you you bond to
it right away you're like I can't let
this go right cuz I shouldn't fit his
outfit at all he's so bonded he finds a
way I might have found it on the street
and be like this is what I needed so get
me are you guys saying that I said I
just let that [ __ ] right because she
would never remember wear a scarf went
anyways he can't no here's why that's
why I asked you what a discover men do
you starve to me [ __ ] to me but if
somebody you're not gonna like openly
steal from somebody brother that's a
timeout with that's what I'm saying I'm
like the reason that you had to do
something is is because he was reaching
us take it back offer yeah and you can't
let no do snatch nothing off you know
and lamb then just let your night
continue so that I might just snatches
your [ __ ] girls hat off her head but
sit on sigh hey what's up honor and
pride is what the scarf meant to you
yeah it's just a thing well don't you
know just disrespect somebody that's
with me
ain't about a scarf it could be about a
yeah anything is just you know grab have
somebody that I'm with and that's and
that's where it escalated and every dude
knows that and it's like if not grandma
she was blackout drunk but let's say she
wasn't mm-hmm if you let that [ __ ] ride
she DiBella you would have gone into a
whole different category in her brain
she's like Oh Hannah I mean if if she
was completely sober and it went down
like that you might
had to put some hands on him what do you
mean like if she was like completely
sober and she knew that was this her
scarf and you know what I'm saying and
there was no question about it no
reasonable doubt then you might add a
purse well you know what I think you
know I'm saying like I they did I sing
on the situation because he saw that she
was blackout drunk and he was like I
ain't gonna believe her I'm drunk keep
saying it's my scarf he was crazy yeah
yeah but that didn't mean he came for
him I don't think so I think it wouldn't
have SK escalated like that if she could
have articulated and just like no this
is my scarf I got this here what the
[ __ ] you talking about you crazy
then I wouldn't have to do talkin I
definitely am wrong I wouldn't have been
and she would have said it way better
did shut the [ __ ] oh oh when it's a Hulk
voice mode yeah it was a fascinating
most fascinating man just cuz I yeah it
was just how it s I think just that that
screaming at the car was just very
something so cinematic about that yeah
that that that yeah once the vehicle and
the person is involved that becomes a
whole nother matters because it's like
you're standing in front of a car do you
not realize that you cannot win against
the car well I wish I I didn't want to I
didn't even want him to amp up anymore
but I would like it was one of those
things where I should be filming this
and I had [ __ ] lots of battery life
at that moment - I said I felt him he
was crazy he wanted me to film yeah
that's what I'm saying like he was
abating you're definitely like but yeah
I a guy with that much anger gets in
your face like that
and talks [ __ ] like and doesn't throw
didn't don't want didn't like push you
didn't even do like a with an index
finger like what do you know just touch
do he like [ __ ] spit on you and spit on
me nothing he just talked yeah man
yeah that's like a classic that's the
classic classic archetype of somebody
who wants you to throw the first punch
like he's looking for confrontation but
it's not willing to start it it happens
all the time more often than not that's
how [ __ ] are in the streets
that are just like I don't want no [ __ ]
but I'm gonna test this [ __ ] and
it's like their way of trying to be
alpha by being able to talk as much [ __ ]
as they can yeah without putting hands
on you and it's like it's it's yeah just
it's them it's the male mind sometimes I
guess his name is the I guess Street
Fighter is an ironic name yes he might
have gotten scraped up a boys do or do
you have any idea what the origin I
think cuz he got his ass whupped a lot
can you talk [ __ ] I'm guessing Street
Fighter yeah probably pulled it pulling
a foot but maybe that's what they mean
what they meant when they say he's
harmless yeah you should have took that
w animals punch set up a trash can for
you we heard MMA we just wanted to get
you going what are you bitching about it
was just we said we do things
differently here when we do our
matchmaking in Kansas City we just set
it up now another fake scenario and then
you fight it and we got hidden cameras
oh it's a camera over here there's a
camera over there do you ever you ever
kick somebody's ass kept like knew you
could kick somebody's ass and kick their
ass just on principle because you had to
kick their ass have you ever done that
before
no like you mean like start the fight so
not start the fight but like a situation
like that where you're like and you are
you're obviously outmatched this person
like no obviously no you could kick this
[ __ ] out like what are you hanging out
in middle school no I mean like this
happened to me before like in college
some guy he was uh he was like us he was
smaller than me but he we were rap
battling and he said a little bit of
some racist [ __ ] and I didn't like it
yeah so hey man you need to cut that
[ __ ] out did you make it rhyme
no I just thought write the cipher was
dead at UH I said ain't man you need to
cut that [ __ ] out he's like whatever and
it he kept going with you slanty-eyed
surprise but like going sound like a man
no more of that no more and he got in my
face
spitting racist bounce more racist man
like but then there's like he literally
was spitting bars on my face oh and I
had I just I had to take him down man
yeah what'd you do I just [ __ ] hit
him a bunch of times
pulled him out onto the port we went and
we rolled around a little bit pulled him
outside I threw him down the porch and I
did like a [ __ ] flying dragon Bruce
Lee kicked to his chest yes from inside
the house to own the fort yeah it's on
the poorest and out side of the porch
this is your house no this was in this
was in college it was that my guy flesh
one he's a DJ at the time and this was
his graduation party I was like a
freshman or a sophomore and then yeah
and then so he was and then they broke
us up but I was so mad at this point and
so shook up I felt I shouldn't have done
this it was so bogus but my guy my guy
grabbed me and then one of my other guy
grabbed him and they like pulled us
apart as we started hustling a little
bit again and then as I was getting
pulled back cuz I was up you saw on the
ground a [ __ ] soccer ball kicked his
do it in the face
[ __ ] [ __ ] just exploded and it was
pretty bad his nose was exploded
yeah just BAM like it was a done deal
did you break his nose I don't know if I
broke his I don't know he was crying and
[ __ ] dawg Jesus he was going after that
but in that case I felt like this guy
needs to get his [ __ ] ass kicked I'm
sorry and I'm not trying to be like
braggadocious about what happened
because I don't feel good about that
soccer ball kick I think after the
flying kick it was
[Laughter]
but the soccer ball kick does I
shouldn't have done that that was 30 he
was dead he's on the ground already the
fight was over I was just emotions took
over you know all that think about dope
that would've been if like you had to go
to the court and have that read in court
like then he did a Dragonball Z kick to
his chest leg sweep oh I forgot about
this part I forgot about that this is a
real this is a real part of the story uh
he moment my homey rod in college know
might as well make beats know you knew
him if you see him anyways alright so he
was with us he can attest to this
so okay so after this after the dragon
ball kick he gets on the ground I come
down the stairs and we square up again
but we're like kind of circling each
other like trying to figure out who's
gonna do what so I have a button-up
shirt i I swear to god this is true 100%
you I had a button-up shirt so I take my
shirt off oh I'll talk about to say you
ripped it over like the Ultimate Warrior
No Oh Hulk oh good I'm not that cool you
take the side button it yes I have the
shirt in my hand and I threw it at his
face to distract him and the [ __ ]
shirt Rep perfectly around his head and
then I [ __ ] around house kicked them
right in the rib goes to the ground it
was some Bruce Lee [ __ ]
it was dope it was like the best fight
I've ever been only for me best fight
ever been it was awesome got hits the
ground and then you know I get on top of
them I just start clocking him and he
gets the shirt off so he starts
defending and now we're just tossing one
around again and that's when they pulled
us apart and then that's when I did the
soccer ball kick which is which makes it
even more unnecessary yeah
the fighters really have when you kick
them I mean but was it over before you
kick them in the face
the fight was over when I dragon ball
kicked him in his chest but yeah I mean
throw in a shirt perfectly over his face
and then beat them up that's pretty
Asian are you gonna ask me the race of
that guy
haha the rates of that guy yeah no nope
uh probably probably a black dude I'm
probably dude Mexican do not use white
he was white he was white
oh yeah yeah it's a white guy well he
was he beating you in the Freestyle
before the races no he was terrible he
wasn't even and he was so drunk that his
freestyle was just like him saying a
bunch of racist [ __ ] without even
rhyming damn so that's just laddie I
[ __ ] [ __ ] go back to
China I don't give a [ __ ] about your
ramen noodles black like [ __ ] that kind
of [ __ ] wasn't even a battle right it
was a cypher at first and then it just
turned into him being racist oh [ __ ] it
was just like yo like you're not even
rhyming like you're just screaming
racist [ __ ] stop the cypher and I was
like now you need to stop like who's
wrong now is he he was all of our homies
he was actually my homie - we were all
friends he just couldn't handle his
liquor that night so I had to kick his
ass
well I guess people were telling them so
I like dude chill out man you're being
[ __ ] crazy
and you just kept going and going once
that spit hit my face though you know
how it is spits immediate fights those
weird
grown man saliva on your face spit is so
weird that like even during football
games where dudes [ __ ] lay it
linebackers lay out running backs coming
over the middle spitting in somebody's
face like that's still you still
remember two NFL players who spit in
people's face like that says yeah it's
such an egregious thing to even off
football yeah it's like it's yeah don't
do that
you don't bid on pizza man Wow yes don't
do that you only do only accidentally in
nice conversations that's it you could
do it then but only light light spittle
don't don't do that is that Dog the
Bounty Hunter how's that yours that Dog
the Bounty Hunter
definitely know that dude 64 you're a
lighting tech do have a mullet though
don't you got I think when you commit to
that mullet it turns off 95% of women
but 5% of them I was like that's hot
just having that long old-school
eighties Ric Ric Flair hair that's all
you need 5% get that 5 [ __ ] the other
ones yeah wrap this email the handsome
Rambler at gmail.com with questions
concerns money t-shirts oh [ __ ] he's a
handsome Rambler of the hens the
handsome Rambla at gmail.com ok share
subscribe whatever Al Jackson anything
you want to plug Al Jackson no man just
the hit me on Twitter at objects and on
Instagram at Al Jackson IG Toni trim
what's up don't it tree I got nothing
man Tony [ __ ]
wait we maybe know who knows we didn't
talk about know topical [ __ ] we just get
up on the mic oh we be rocking this [ __ ]
I got my pen in my pad and my socks in
this [ __ ] and his gibberish rapping and
I'm a knocking the [ __ ] ain't bad for
numbers talkin this [ __ ] got all cheese
Thursdays and I'm like Christopher
Walken in this business whatever I was
kind of awkward is just alright
see that's fluid that's how you know I'm
not a real rapper because I want Tony
did the weird breath thing I was like I
guess I'm done hahaha other other
skilled rappers were rap do the weird
raps and figure out how to have we wait
whatever man bliss if you made it this
far thank you
jobless
[Music]